und jetzt reden wir mal über lobbyismus
über diabetes und über zucker bei
diabetikern mit corona ist das
mortalitätsrisiko tatsächlich um fast 50
prozent höher
wahrscheinlich auch deswegen ist die
zucker lobby gerade so besonders aktiv
und versucht alles zu verhindern was das
zuckergeschäft stören könnte zucker ist
ja eine unglaublich preiswerte droge mit
der schon unsere kleinsten angefixt
werden ja kinder lieben zucker sagt man
immer so aber stimmt das überhaupt mein
sender hat das jetzt endlich mal
wissenschaftlich überprüft kinder lieben
eis denn eis ist süß was kinder hingegen
gar nicht leiden können ist wenn man ihm
was süßes wegnimmt
[Musik]
ich habe mich noch nie geschehen fürs
zdf zu arbeiten heute ist es soweit
was sollte das denn bitte und was kommt
als nächstes
das große zdf experiment was passiert
eigentlich wenn man einem süßen
kleinkind volle möhre einen fußballer
ins gesicht schießt die antwort in ihrem
zdf mit dem zweiten welt nun besser ein
spaß für fast die ganze familie
doch zurück zur zucker lobby das war ja
unser thema wie behaupten einfach weiter
zucker übergewicht und diabetes hätten
nichts miteinander zu tun sagen
wenn überhaupt seien die fetten schuld
schon jung nicht die fetten die fette
sagen die eu recht verhindert im moment
national verpflichtende
lebensmittelampeln auf der verpackung
der nutrias chor in deutschland ist ja
zum beispiel freiwillig ja so läuft das
wenn in brüssel auf ein
verbraucherschützer 100
industrielobbyisten kommen wie sie hier
oder eben auch nicht
entweder fährt man vor der grundschule
30 oder eben auch nicht eine milliarde
sage und schreibe eine milliarde haben
lobbyverbände ausgegeben um eine ampel
pflicht zu verhindern
klar jeder soll futtern was er will aber
der verbraucher muss dann ja wenigstens
transparent und ehrlich informiert
werden ich fordere endlich realistische
produktbezeichnungen wie haribo fette
schweine wenn man mehr als eine tüte ist
wird man ein fettes schwein auch sehr
lecker ritter bloß kein sport und
natürlich die beliebten bonbons nimmt
zwei kilo pro woche zu plus der
klassiker dicke kinder schokolade zucker
obwohl das zeug schon ohne corona
gigantische schäden im gesundheitssystem
verursacht müssen viele zocker sorten
bis heute auf der packung nicht als
zucker bezeichnet werden und unsere
ernährung ministerin hält sich bei sowas
ja traditionell raus der staat macht
nicht den geschmack und ich bin auch
nicht
er hat die geschmacks nanny der region
der nation also wie deutschland schmeckt
schreibt die politik nicht vor wie
deutschland schmeckt ja vielen dank an
die sympathische marken botschafterin
von nestlé klöckner hat sogar den
freiwilligen utri score solange
ausgebremst wie irgend möglich und wenn
sie zu hause wirklich wissen wollen wie
deutschland schmeckt ungefähr so mein
reden
die eu-kommission hat die idee mit der
pflicht ampel erst mal auf eis gelegt
bis ende 2022 läuft gerade für unsere
lobbyisten übrigens auch beim inzwischen
fast völlig entkernten lieferketten
gesetz ist nicht mehr viel von übrig
oder noch ein aktuelles beispiel für top
lobbyarbeit das sogenannte umwandlungs
verbot von miet in eigentumswohnungen
hatte die groko wissen sie vielleicht
mit viel trara beschlossen als mittel
gegen die verdrängung von mietern kommt
jetzt wohl nicht warum nicht wir
schalten wir live zu valerie niehaus sie
ist maklerin und pressesprecherin vom
eigentümerverband haus und grund frau
mehr aus wie hat die immobilien lobby
das denn wieder hingekriegt
henkel ich bin gleich bei ihm ich habe
ja gerade noch eine besichtigung ja
sonst verliere ich bares geld während
ich mit ihnen rum la so also sie sind
der investmentbanker und sie der
unternehmensberater und sie sind die
alleinerziehende mutter mit der
halbtagsstelle ja super schönen abend
noch
manchmal allein erziehend na ja herr
welke ich habe gehört andere branchen
hätten gerade irgendwie krise also keine
handlung bei uns läuft's bombe und er
denkt sich diese ihrer groko 2018 ein
gesetz aus dass es quasi verbietet aus
mietwohnungen eigentumswohnungen zu warm
wurde zum glück verhindert von unseren
besten mann in berlin
federführend beim gesetz das ministerium
von horst seehofer
zwei jahre später gibt es gerade mal
einen referentenentwurf und vor knapp
drei wochen verschwindet auch das
vereinbarte umwandlungs verbot aus
diesem entwurf als scheiße war in
deutschland fehlen rund 1,9 millionen
bezahlbare wohnung wozu haben wir dann
überhaupt noch eine regierung wenn
gesetze am ende sowieso von lobbyisten
geschrieben werden
wir haben ja gar nichts geschrieben wir
haben nur was gestrichen ist etwas
völlig anderes also so ein spekulant der
ein großes mietshaus kauft um die
wohnungen dann einzeln weiter zu
verhökern der macht das ja nicht weil er
böse ist gut auch aber vor allem bietet
er doch den mietern eine chance also die
cdu hat das begriffen wir sind immer die
pace des eigentums gewiesen wir wollen
mehr mieter zu eigentümern machen und
das wird mit dem umwandlungs verbot
gerade verhindert das klingt jetzt
tatsächlich wie hohn in den ohren der
münchner mieterin mitte die kaum wissen
wie sie sich die miete nächsten monat
leisten können wenn sie denen erzählen
dass jedoch eine tolle chance haben wenn
sie also ihre mietwohnung
eigentumswohnungen wochen die man für
10.000 euro pro quadratmeter in münchen
anbietet nur 10.000 pro quadratmeter wo
in münchen soll das denn sei das kaufe
ich selber wenn wir das mit dem
umwandeln nicht mehr machen dürfen
um das gesocks um weniger solvente
mieter loszuwerden dann zwingt man uns
diese leute weiter mit dem anderen trick
raus zu jagen modernisierung der
vermieter kündigt weitere
modernisierungen an wie den einbau einer
video gegensprechanlage und eines
aufzugs
damit steigt die miete von bisher 6 145
euro auf fast 3.000 euro ja das klingt
hart aber so will es die natur der
stärkere also finanzstärkere schöne
mieter ersetzt den armen hässlichen das
circle of life acuna matata wirklich wie
macht ihr das auch das bau gebot dass
käufer von brachflächen zum bauen
verpflichtet hätte ist aus dem entwurf
verschwunden
gucken sie mal
die kleinste violine der welt so und
jetzt entscheide ich wäre dieses
luxuriöse anderthalb zimmer läuft
bekommt ich würde sagen ihr zwei
hübschen regel das jetzt mal wie echte
männer erkämpft
[Musik]
ich mache das immer ein bisschen geil
valerie niehaus
was wie viel euro und und alles sobald
wir eine million abonnenten liebe liebe
liebe fans ich würde mich so was schon
freuen wenn ihr ein abo dallas auch hier
er würde den gern etwas unglücklich
macht